i think what's quite interesting what
the scottish tourists have already come
out with
which is essentially a fervor devolution
deal that hands the scottish parliament
all power over income tax except the
level of the personal lines
i think this is a sign that the scottish
referendum isn't going to be the end of
the
matter um even if scotland votes no far
more power's going to go
from westminster to hollywood um now i
mean that raises a question about what
you do about england it's going to make
all the asymmetries in the union
even more profound now it used to be
said that the answer to the western
being question
that the fact that scottish mps can vote
on on matters that affect england but
english mps can't vote on some matters
so devolved matters that affect scotland
what's to stop asking it i don't think
you can do that now because of ukip
ukip are quite clear that they want an
english parliament and a fully federal
uk
i mean that means that both the labour
and the tourists are going to have to
have an answer between this question
i think people are slowly starting to
wake up to how close the referendum
is we had gordon brown in westminster on
monday speaking to a lot of journalists
where basically
he took every opportunity to in a very
soft voice
criticize david cameron's handling of
the debate
overall he talked about politicians
coming up to scotland to say britain
says no to this britain says no to that
he managed to slip in just in a sentence
that a lot of political correspondents
from scotland who were sitting in the
press gallery
initially missed the suggestion that
david cameron should debate
alex salmon so there's still that kind
of infighting you do have to feel for
alistar darling who's trying to hold
together this better together campaign
which doesn't really work together at
all they're talking about the union but
they can't even unite as they campaign
for it
that's meant to kill nationalism stone
dead yeah it's resulted in a referendum
on independence
um it has resulted in a situation where
politicians of westminster are
uh profoundly ignorant of what is going
on in hollywood if you talk to
to to politicians of all parties when
they go to scotland
they are petrified about being asked
questions because they don't know what's
happening i mean they probably have
about as much idea of what is going on
in
scottish domestic politics as they do
what is going on in american domestic
politics
it has become a real problem that if you
listen to today program in the morning
go through the number of items that
don't apply to scotland in the in the
british news stories
british inverted commerce and it's huge
and it's a massive problem
you've got a situation where you've got
two political elites talking past each
other you've got separate national
political conversations
i think it's important that there are
cultural figures coming out remember
this as well
the the cultural side of the of the yes
campaign has
so far been much stronger but i thought
jk rowling's statement as well was
really interesting because
she preempted as james said the backlash
from the extreme wing of the
nationalists
which is really important in turning
swing voters against the nationalists
because if they see it as being an
irrational
overly emotional vindictive campaign
then that will turn them away from it in
the same way as swing voters
down here are turned off party leaders
if there seem to be out of touch they're
not seem to be nice enough
that's a key factor i think also the
fact that she then listed her scottish
credentials and said that she suspected
that she was going to be
questioned for not being scottish enough
is another
important thing that she's actually
saying that people are trying to be true
nationalists are trying to exclude
people from the debate i mean he's also
a scot who stayed in scotland i mean
this is important i think
one of the things that has come out in
this campaign is that that
for example down here we would all think
of as darling danny alexander
as scots as they are scots who sit for
scottish seats you know um
but up there there is some taint on them
in the debate because they sit in the
westminster parliament not the scottish
parliament
they choose them to make their career
down here um i mean the fact that jk
rowling has a big house in edinburgh
that this is her base
what will make this a particularly uh
particularly
powerful endorsement of the union